we've done a couple of videos on binary
search big fan right you know it's great
it has some pros and cons one of the
pros is that look UPS very very fast one
of the cons is you have to sort the data
and there are lots of other data
structures available to us that we could
use but serve slightly different
purposes and again they have pros and
cons as well so today we're going to
start looking at hashmaps or hash sets
depending on how you're using them which
are a very different way of storing your
data but they're very very popular so
for example if you've used python the
dictionary is implemented as a hash map
almost all languages will have a data
structure that does or multiple data
structures that does something like this
because of the benefits that they have
for storing data and looking up very
very
quickly so let's think a bit about the
speed of binary search let's put aside
the fact that we had to sort the data
that was a bit of a pain it takes a long
time but once the data is sorted the
lookup if you remember is O log n so
it's log that's how it scales right yeah
that's how it scales so if your size of
your data is n if your list doubles in
size your log two of n only goes up by
one right which basically means you have
to do one additional lookup which is of
no real concern right for most computers
so it means that it's scales very very
well with the size of your data now that
log two of n is good right what's better
is log is 01 right o1 says it doesn't
mean that you only have to do one
operation right that's I think a common
misconception it it just means that
there is no relationship between the
speed of lookup really and the number of
elements in your list so if your list is
100 elements or a thousand elements it's
still just the same amount of
computation you have to to do that
lookup right so o1 is obviously the
ideal case and there are some data
structures that offer you this you would
think why would you use binary search
then well each of these have their pros
and cons but I just wanted to talk about
hashsets today or hashmaps because they
are one of these data structures right
and they are very very popular what is a
hash we've talked about cryptographic
hashes before hash function takes some
string right let's say a BC and it turns
it into some fixed length string that's
not usually three long these sort of
hashes that we're looking at today are a
little bit different they are a
numerical code that represents some
object in memory that we're trying to
put into our data structure so a hashset
is essentially a large list of numbers
indexed by their hash rather than by
themselves so you might have a very
large list of numbers
right and this is zero and this is one
and this is two and this is three dot
dot dot dot dot all the way up to the
maximum size of your set so let's say
10,000 right so I'm going to do
9999 here now I nearly made a mistake so
now these are not your actual values
these are the hashes of those values so
you have let's say you have a string or
you have an object or a class or you
have a number you hash it into here and
it comes out as four four and then you
can put your
object in here right and when you have
object two comes along and you get you
compute a hash on it and it and it comes
up as 770 so down here somewhere you
have this object you know with 770 as
his hash let's talk about how his hash
is calculated if you have an integer
right and you want your hash to also be
an integer then there is no there's
nothing to do right the hash is the
number okay that works well if you have
something for example if you're trying
to return a
32bit hash value and you've got a 64-bit
number then what you would commonly do
is take the two hares and EXO them
together and then for a string you have
to do a computation that combines each
of the characters for every position in
the string for example and so the more
complicated your object perhaps the more
complicated hash is we're going to look
at integers today just because for
Simplicity but it these are usually
quite fast and they're not they don't
have to be cryptographically secure
right but the same restrictions that
we've talked about previously on on you
know cryptographic hashes they don't
hold here what we're looking for here is
a broadly good distribution of our
values around this list so it's a bit of
a way of kind of like boiling it down or
abbreviating yes it's like a sort of
fingerprint yes but very very simplistic
one we'll talk about what happens when
two objects have the same hash in a
moment but you're not absolutely
concerned about that right it does it's
going to happen I mean the thing to
think about is if we've got our list of
numbers here it's only 10,000 long and
we've got 12,000 different objects if we
find a way of hashing them into this
list of 10,000 numbers by definition
some of them are going to have the same
hash right um and in fact this is what
we would normally do so normally you
will hash set would have a capacity
right in this case 10,000 and so we
actually calculate that the actual hash
lookup value right is going to be the
hash of our integer hash of I which is
going to be itself or some other
complicated way of doing it mod remember
mod yeah it's come back mod our capacity
which I'm just going to right C right
like this so mod 10,000 or something
like this and this means that if your
number is 12,000 it's going to loop back
around to be 2,000 on this set and it
also means that broadly speaking as long
as your original hashes are fairly
uniform in their distribution their
positions on this are also going to be
fairly uniform right and that avoids too
many too many values clumping around
zero for example and no one nothing at
four right that's the idea so how do we
deal with collisions because that will
happen right and if you have a imagine
collisions where two things boil down be
the same imagine that you had a capacity
that was equal to the number of possible
values you could have and you had a
hashing function that always gave unique
values then we wouldn't have any
collisions right because they'd all just
go into you know into the correct place
and that'll be fine that is unlikely to
happen because you know there's issues
of memory for example we want to put 1.2
billion items into our set you might not
have a maximum capacity of 1 you might
but in even then your hash function
might not be perfect and you know for
Strings and things might produce the
same hash for some complicated strings
so we're going to get some collisions so
what do you do well this is what you do
when you when you insert something into
this you say okay what what is the hash
of this value mod C so let's say that
that gives us a value of four right so
we come in here and we look oh hang on a
minute there's already something in the
four so what we do is we create a little
list at this at this position where we
have object two like you see like this
now this list is a slower data structure
because we're doing that linear search
but it's only got two objects in it so
this is much much faster so we have
another object object four that's coming
up this time and maybe it has a hash of
two so we put in a new one and that's
fine object in here and then we have
another one so this gets appended onto
here object two I'm giving them all the
same names my nameing convention is
rubbish you just hold lots of little
lists at each of these indices such that
anything that has the same hand hash
just gets put into this short list into
if your hash function is good and so
everything is is is reasonably well
distributed then you'll find that you
have roughly the same number in each
bucket that's kind of the idea now
what's the speed of lookup of this well
in the best case it's 01 because you say
okay is 17 in the data set you hash it
it comes out of 17 let's say you look
and there is always not an object there
and it's so you're done that's all you
have to do in a slightly worst case you
have a short list that you have to look
through right in the in the absolute
worst casee you have all of the items
have received the same hash and so you
have literally a list of length n here
right so in a sense the best case
scenario for a hash set is 01 and the
worst case is o
n but you rarely see o right if you've
given any thought to your design right
at all okay and so and it doesn't tend
to happen if if you are looking for the
hash 17 why is that quicker than looking
for 17 in say an AR raay like not right
and that's that's really interesting so
one of the downsides of a hash is it
there is a bit of memory and a bit of
computational overhead this 01 in some
sense is ever slightly worse than the
o01 array lookup that you would do where
you just index at 17 but for that to
work you would have to know that you
were only ever going to see indices that
were numbers and were between these two
values right so it might be that you
have that exact situation right you know
you're only going to have one between a
number between zero and 10,000 and so
and you're never going to have
duplicates and you're never going to
have collisions so just have an array
right you don't need to use a hashset
you don't need to use a dictionary in
Python to do that which is why we have
lists so again it comes back to that
idea of think a little bit about why
you're using a specific data structure
right just because you can have a list
of keys like this and and Associated
values or not doesn't mean you just have
to right and so um indexing just
straight off using a number is always
going to be the fastest way of doing it
I've had to go implementing this in p
and let's have a look so I implemented
this as a short class now of course
you'd be ill advised to use this class
right because it's a perfectly good set
in Python right which is called a set
and you can use that and it implements
this but mostly in C and it's much much
faster so definitely use that um let's
just draw a brief distinction between
the two types A hashset is one where you
store only the numbers and you're
essentially trying to work out what's in
there and what's not in there and you
can do things you can do standard set
notation things from mathematics so for
example intersection of sets the union
of sets and things like this um this was
for a long time in Python implemented
literally as a dictionary um it's just
you never used for values a dictionary
is where you have your set of keys which
are this hashmap and then they link to
something that has a value like an index
in a book it is so your hashes are your
index into your element right so a set
doesn't have the actual element it just
has the indices right they they are both
implemented often in very very similar
ways because they're essentially the
same data structure it's just one of
them then has a pointer to something
else and perhaps we can look at
extending this to dictionaries in a
different video I partially implemented
a class here called hashset it has a
capacity which is the essentially the
size of the underlying data structure
that we're using which is a which is a
list and I initialize that data to have
nothing in it right so just be a long
list of nothing where when we start to
put elements in we can create a little
entry there and then there's really only
a few functions we have to implement I'm
not implementing most of the set
functions because you know I've got
other things to do but there's an you
want to be able to add an item ideally
you want to be able to remove an item
although I haven't implemented this and
you want to use the contains function to
be able to use the in keyword so
remember when we were doing binary
search we we tested against um whether
something was in 17 was in our list
we'll be able to do that on this set
we'll be able to say is 17 in our set so
how do we implement this well actually
there's very little code involved python
implements an underlying hash function
that you can use rather than writing
your own every time right you could
write your own if you were very if you
had had a specific data structure you
were very worried about and you wanted
maximum speed um in Python the hash of
an integer is just the integer we knew
we knew this a hash of a string will be
calculated in a different way but will
still give you a number right it could
be very large and it could be positive
or negative but it will be a number in
this case we're only really looking at
integers for the sake of simplicity so
at the beginning of AD I'm going to have
our integer I that I'm trying to add
into our hash set we're going to create
the hash of I and then we're going to
call H mod the capacity of our data so
that we can run this on a very small
hashset with very few bins or a very
large hashset with lots and lots of bins
and then actually deciding whether
something's already in the data is quite
easy we look up the data element at the
correct index which is given by hash our
hash mod the capacity and then we say if
it's not none which means that there's
already something in there we append it
to the list that's in there we add it
onto the list if it is none we just
create a new little list at that
location with our single line item in it
and then really the contains function is
exactly the same so in Python if you
implement this underscore underscore
contains function what you're doing is
is allowing it to use the in keyword
essentially and so we're going to say
okay we're going to create our hash in
the exact same way we're going to again
calculate the modulo so that we are
within our capacity limit and then we
just say Okay is the data at that
location none if it's
not can we find our value we're looking
for in that little list right and
hopefully that list isn't too long so we
can just use the in keyword which will
just be a little linear search but it
won't take too long there are better
ways to implement hashmaps right than
this this is a demonstration of a kind
of minimum Bare Bones implementation
that does work at least as far as I know
I've also written a print function so I
can see what's in this in the uh in the
set so let's test it out right so I'm
going to run python minus IM map.
piy okay we're in Python and we have our
hash set now so we're going to create a
new one how many elements do we want to
test it with same numbers again or
slightly fewer just for say save
ourselves some time all right so ruce
let's say our hash set H is equal to a
hash set with a maximum size of let's
say a million elements right what does
this mean well it means that our
underlying data structure is only a
million in size it doesn't mean we can
only store a million elements because
some of them just might have the same
hash right um You can really store as
many elements as you want but of course
the more you store Beyond Your Capacity
the more more collisions you're going to
have the slower it will get right so
let's create an now our random in Array
of um in fact let's let's just do our
numbers like we did before right so
that's much much easier so let's say we
have our list which is equal to I for I
in range and then let's say we're going
to put 10 million in there right so that
means we're going to have around 10 in
each of our bins right which means there
short linear search for a lookup but not
anything like a linear search across
across 10 million elements so if I look
at if I look at list first 10 items then
you have n to n so now we can see we can
add all these items into our hash set
right which is a little bit of a slow
proces but shouldn't be too bad so we
can say for uh integer in uh
list h. add
I and it's just going to go off and do
that by the way if you use the actual
python set it's much much faster right
it's faster because it has finished now
just just not that it's not that bad
it's faster because this should be done
in low level C code right what I'm doing
is a lot of intermediate python code
checking variables going back to C
coming back again there's a lot of
waiting around for things that happen
Okay so now we can see if 17 is in our
hashset so we can say 17 in h and it
says true right and that works and it
worked really really quickly even though
we've got a 10 million value so we can
find is's another one in there so we
could say you know
999,999 in h it is now if we take that
out of a list just like we you know
we've done before so we could say okay
so LS so hash I can't take it out of the
list cuz I didn't I didn't implement the
remove function did
I um well let's just implement it
quickly now uh you can speed fast
forward this bit um it's going to be
exactly the same as our insert function
except we're going to delete it
instead in h yeah okay so I've I've I've
now added a remove function this will
teach me to be lazy um where is very
very similar to the ad function except
instead of a um appending a new item to
a list we're going to remove it from
that list if it's there okay so now
let's test this out so we we know that
999999 is in h so let's now remove it
from H h.
remove right that seems to have done
something so now can we say a uh
999999 in h false right and actually if
we look at the data structure we can see
that so if we go um if we do hash on of
999999 it should be the same number
again because we already said that
hashes in Python just return a number
for an integer so now let's look at our
data structure at that location so if we
look at the what what we'll find is
we'll find all the numbers that module
over capacity are the same are
999999 so let's have a quick look so if
we go H do data
at nine one shouldn't normally look at
the internals of a data structure like
this but sometimes it's useful for
learning you can see we've got 1,
999,999 we also have 2, 999,9 all the
increments of a million right on this
value okay except for
999,999 which we removed and I'm now
wishing I picked a shorter number to say
but anyway
so a hash set is is an extremely useful
um data structure right so in Python
using a set will allow you to to very
quickly find what numbers are in what
lists finding the numbers that are
common between two lists and things like
this is extremely useful perhaps the
extended version is the one you see most
of all which is the dictionary right so
in a dictionary we now add to these
indices we add an actual item that we
can add so you have key value Pairs and
this hashmap is perhaps something to
look at next time global trading firm
and computer file supporter James straet
have made a little puzzle for us
all here it is it involves placing
numbers in this Manhattan grid
representing skyscrapers and you got to
figure out what Heights of skyscrapers
block other ones does it look like
something you could crack now the
puzzle's just for fun but it is aimed at
drawing a bit of attention to Jane
Street's summer am event which is going
to be in New York that's the Academy of
math and programming now this is
something for recent high school
graduates to come to New York and
immerse themselves in things like Game
Theory programming data anal analysis
all that good stuff and it's aimed at
opening doors to students who perhaps
have faced barriers to getting Advanced
stem education opportunities like this
it's an amazing program and it's a very
generous opportunity there are more
details in the video description it's
well worth a look and by the way you
don't have to complete the skyscraper
puzzle to apply that's just something
they've made for fun and you can do the
puzzle even if you're not interested in
the thing if you want to find out more
there's going to be links in all the
usual places you know the video
description comments things you can
click on check it out and thanks to Jane
Street for supporting this
[Music]
episode